This meeting is being recorded.
OK, then.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to this meeting of the Preservation Board.
I'm going to call a roll and determine who is here.
I am present.
Commissioner Robinson, are you here?
Yes.
Commissioner Hamilton, are you here?
Commissioner Killeen, are you here?
Present.
Richardson, Commissioner Allen, are you here?
Commissioner Hamacher, are you here?
Yes.
Alderman Coder, are you here?
Yes, sir, here.
Okay.
Let's make Commissioner Richardson and Commissioner Hamilton disappear.
Commissioners.
Have you had a chance to read the minutes from the January 23rd meeting, anyone?
And if so, is there a motion to approve them?
I move to approve the minutes from the January, what's the date?
23rd.
January 23rd, 2023 preservation board meeting.
Thank you, sir.
Is there a second?
I second.
Motion is accepted.
Any discussion?
Hearing none.
All those in favor of adopting the minutes
of approving minutes for January 23rd, 2023, signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Opposed?
Abstain?
Okay, those will be approved minutes.
Commissioners, take a look down through today's agenda and tell me if there is any item here from which you need to recuse yourself.
Item B from Mike Tulane, please.
Okay.
Anybody else?
Good enough.
Okay, looking down through the order here.
Is this order satisfactory to everybody?
Okay, then this will be the order.
I'm going to call the roll.
And voting today will be Robinson, Killeen, Allen, Hamilcar, Coder.
Chair will vote last.
We'll generally vote only to break a tie.
Meg, have you got some announcements to make?
Yes, I just want to remind everybody that the meeting is being recorded.
Also, if you would like to speak on an agenda item, please put your full name and the address of the agenda item in the chat.
Those chats will only come to the host and co-host, not to everyone.
We will then call on you, and we will give the chair your name at the appointed time, and you will be called on at that time.
We ask that everyone in the room stay muted unless you're speaking.
And also that you use your first and your last name.
I noticed there are a few people with only their first names here in the room.
Please go in and add your last name so that we know who is here.
Thank you.
Barb Burkett, have you any advice or instructions to give to commissioners?
Only advice I've heard before.
When it's time for you to vote, please make sure you turn your cameras on.
And if you have any technical difficulty, please make
the Cultural Resources Director aware of it, and that will do.
Excellent.
Thank you both very much.
Ladies and gentlemen, we're gonna hear appeals of the director's denials first, and I would like to remind both staff and those who wish to testify, including the appellants, that I'm going to ask you to state your name, your zip code, and I will ask you to affirm that you are telling the truth, or tell me that you're not gonna be telling the truth.
We're building a record.
This is like administrative law.
We begin agenda item A3326 South 18th Street.
Okay.
I want to say that I'm reading from a tablet here because once again, the director did not give me a printed version of this agenda.
We will try and rectify that in the future, Mr. Calo.
If Mr. Calo asks for such a thing, then he will get it.
Bob, you are now the new director.
Hey.
It's a whole new world, guys.
Okay, so start out Bob Bettis with staff will tell the truth.
I live in St.
Louis at 63139.
So there's my zip code for you.
I need to enter in the enabling ordinance 64689 as amended by 69423, the Benton Park ordinance 67175, my presentation, step report and a PowerPoint.
Good.
Okay.
Can you guys see the PowerPoint?
Not yet.
Okay.
One second, I apologize.
Now we can.
Yay, okay, great.
Okay, this item was heard briefly last month.
The applicant, staff, and the neighborhood had asked for a deferment so the applicant could meet with the Benton Park Neighborhood Group to discuss this project.
From what I gather, that did not occur, though, unfortunately.
I'm just going to go through the report real quick.
And then Benton Park is present.
They have also sent you a letter so you know their stance on the project.
OK.
This is an appeal at 3326 South 18th Street in the Benton Park Local Historic District.
This is the property in question.
And while we're looking at it, the retaining walls you see in front of you are also the items in question.
It's this two-tiered wall system.
So all four of those little walls are what's part of the appeal.
Some quick context for you.
It's kind of on the Eastern edge of Benton park, just North of Cherokee street.
Here's some street level context.
It's a good time to point out that the entire length of South 18th street on that East side, um, has, uh, uh, Versa lock retaining walls already in place.
Those were all put in place prior to Benton park becoming a local historic district.
So they were not reviewed, obviously because they predate the code.
So they are a non-compliant feature, but they predate the code.
Here's another shot of the subject property.
I'd like to note something on this picture as well.
You'll see a brick wall just kind of behind this chain link fence.
That brick wall went through our office for approval back in 2013.
So the previous owner went through the board, I'm sorry, went through staff
to get that wall, which is compliant, approved.
It was built, I believe, just all brick with a cast cap.
So that's a compliant wall that was built previously.
And here's a shot of that wall.
And again, you can also see the unfinished first lock wall to the left that's in question today.
On the left is the previous appearance.
It's a very steep slope, but there's no way of getting around that.
So obviously there was some need to fix that slope, but what was constructed was done without permits and does not meet code.
So what Benton Park Code says, we've all been through retaining walls before.
If you're going to do a retaining wall, it needs to be based on a model example, have a natural stone coarsed veneer that is based on the example, or a brick veneer.
Obviously what you see before you is none of that.
It's a versalock retaining wall.
So what happened,
Current owner is flipping the property, and he came through before with some other work on the rear of the property, including also some flat work, and also just the steps at the top that were entering the building.
So everything else, the retaining walls were not part of that original permit.
He can explain to you as to why he constructed those, but again, that's what's in question.
So I'm not missing anything else.
Uh, again, you, you were sent a letter, um, the Bend park, uh, neighborhood group did not hear from the applicants since the last meeting.
So they are at this point in time stating that they are going to support the director's denial of the application.
Um, if the application, um, I believe they're going to meet again sometime in early March.
So if the applicant can get before them again, he's going to ask for a deferral.
I believe today the applicant is.
But anyway, staff recommends that the board uphold the director's denial as the install wall does not meet the Benton Park local historic standards for canning walls.
Any questions?
Commissioners, questions for Bob?
Just one question.
Bob, would that brick wall be eligible to be considered a model example?
No, sir.
It has to be an actual period wall.
So it needs to be based on something.
But there are canning walls within the district that has that.
It's definitely a good idea that that would be something they could do to put a veneer on that wall because there's plenty in the neighborhood that would meet that criteria.
Thank you.
Do you mean put a veneer over the front of the wall?
Bill, wait a second, please.
Okay.
Commissioners, further questions for Bob?
Okay, Bob, out of curiosity, is there anybody here to speak besides the appellant?
Again, Tim Mulligan, I believe, is here.
Anybody else signed up to speak yet?
OK, let me look and check on my chat one sec as we're getting conflicting chats.
So please bear with me one sec.
I think it looks nice.
Bill, OK, please mute, Bill, please.
OK, so Tim Mulligan is here to speak on the item for South 18th Street.
I want to reiterate to everybody who's in the room, if you want to speak, would you please actually send your request to the send request here?
Send and speak here, please.
There's one of the windows you'll see on there.
One sec.
It says sign up to speak here, please send
your chat to that window, that'd be great.
Okay, yeah, so we have Mr. Mulligan is here to speak, sir.
That's good to know in case we are asked to defer this.
I don't want to drag citizens to a meeting and then defer the item.
Okay, is the appellant present?
Yes, Mr. McCracken is here.
Bill McCracken.
Yes.
Mr. McCracken, could you put your full name
My name's William McCracken.
I can't get back to the screen.
I'm having a little difficulty working.
It's the first Zoom meeting I've ever been to, and I'm a little confused.
Do you see where your mouse is?
I'm on a phone.
As I say, I'm on a phone.
There you go.
Perfect.
Good work.
I don't know what to do.
There you go.
Mr. McCracken, is your testimony going to be the truth?
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Good.
What do you want us to do?
I would like you to defer this so I can meet with the people from the Bend Park Neighborhood Committee.
I missed it last week or two weeks ago because I was sick.
I'd like to meet with them and see what they think because that should be my proper steps in getting this done.
I was hoping I could do that before you-all made a decision on it.
Tim Mulligan, it looks like you're the only person here to speak on this issue.
How do you feel about a deferment?
That would be a great opportunity to hear from the owner and see what we can come up with.
OK.
Commissioners, how do you all feel about it?
OK to defer?
That's fine.
OK.
Commissioners, there's a motion on the floor to defer this matter.
And I assume that one of the this fines is a second.
All those in favor of deferring this signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Opposed?
OK.
Many, many ayes.
The motion carries.
And we will defer this.
And we'll report on a future agenda.
OK.
Well, thank you.
And I'll make sure to hit the next meeting.
Thank you.
There we go.
Okay.
Commissioners.
Very exciting start to the meeting.
Let's call agenda item B to North Taylor Avenue.
Okay.
Again, Bob bet us with staff.
I'll tell the truth.
I still live at 63139.
Mr. Callow.
I'm going to enter in a new ordinance 64689 as amended by 69423.
Central West End Ordinance, which is 5678 as amended by 69423, my presentation, PowerPoint, and staff report.
Okay, so we have, this is the property in question, it's at 462 North Taylor and Central West End.
The proposal that came in to install two fabric awnings, one on the alley side, on the south side, and one on the east side, which faces onto the parking lot.
This is the property in question.
This is the North Taylor side facing east.
It's kind of an odd building.
It's set back far off of Olive.
So you see it's back here, set far back.
There is a brick wall that fronts along Olive that kind of screens the view from the street.
This is a, I'm looking kind of northeast and a bird's-eye view, northwest bird's-eye view, and the two green dots on my little map here show the proposed locations of the awnings.
Here's some street-level context.
On the photograph on the top here, the awnings are going to go in this general area here, and then we're looking south.
On Taylor, building questions to the left.
This is on Olive.
At right, you can see the wall, the building is set far off the street, looking west on Olive.
Okay, so what the Central West End Code says for awnings is that awnings must fit within the masonry opening which they intend to cover.
So staff takes that literally in that it needs to fit within the masonry opening of a window or a door or a storefront.
The proposed awnings in this case are just two different kinds of awning setups.
They're both trying to keep water out of two basement entrances.
You can see that here.
My sad little mock-up I did for you shows the awning on the south side actually covers two windows, but it projects over that well that goes down to the basement.
And then on the east facade, the awning actually sits below the sills of the window, but still covers that longer stretch of stairwell that goes down.
Neither awning meet the code because they don't fit that definition within the Mesa opening.
So again, these are a few more shots.
This is the alley view looking back at the property.
And then it's kind of important to show the one on Olive Street.
You would barely see the one from Olive based on the large wall that faces the street.
This was the submittal from the applicant showing the swatch of green fabric.
And we're back here.
So again,
What the code says is it's within the opening, so staff denied the application.
We did speak with the applicant early on, as well as the awning company, and they felt that this was their best solution to keep the water out.
So there really wasn't any other items or ways to do this explore.
They thought this was the best way to proceed, and they know the process they've been through before, so they chose to appeal our denial.
So given that, staff recommends that the board upholds director's denial of the installation of the two awnings.
You should have gotten a letter today from Central West End, from us.
I do believe that they conditionally support the applicant's request.
They wish for a color change.
Mr. Dwyer is here to speak on the item from the neighborhood.
So any questions?
Any questions for Bob, commissioners?
Bob, to your knowledge, were there ever awnings over those openings?
I would guess no, but I don't want to say that specifically.
I would just guess no.
I have no definitive answer for that.
Did you look down in that stairwell hole and see if there's a drain down there?
Well, I did not.
Okay.
Did not.
It seems to be a problem that's been about 85 years in the making.
True.
That's true.
And Mr. Wolfgram is also the applicant.
Maybe he can shed some light on the actual specifics on their problems.
OK, that's cool.
Do we have people signed up to speak for this one besides the appellant?
Jim Dwyer is here also.
Perfect.
We're just double checking.
We're double checking here real quick.
No, just Mr. Dwyer.
Great.
OK, let's hear from the appellant, please.
Good afternoon.
Thank you for having me.
Can you hear me OK?
Yes, we can tell us your zip code 63108 and Mr welcome is your testimony going to be the truth, yes, sir okay proceed.
Great um we've had some intrusion of water through the years, but the last August rain the Tuesday Thursday rain that.
affected many of us in this area was by far the worst that we've experienced, and so we have a kind of multi phased approach to trying to.
remediate the water.
And I truly believe that this is the new normal in buildings have to harden their assets against global warming.
And so that's the purpose for this.
And there are drains at the bottom of each stairwell.
We've also consulted outside contractors to see if they could install a sump pump or something that would also
help us alleviate when there's so much water rainfall coming down that we get intrusion of water and in the alley stairwell, there's not room for some pump in the, in the parking lot side they thought maybe they could but
Just to answer the previous question, there are drains listed in each.
And I know Jim Dwyer on behalf of his committee have recommended a color change, and that's certainly no problem whatsoever.
So, I mean, there are other things that we're doing as well, but we feel that this is the best solution to ameliorate the flooding problems that we've had in the past.
And I will mention,
Before this August rain, we had those drains snaked in July, and we have them on a routine maintenance to keep them open.
So they were fully open during that intrusion.
You know, Klan Dwyer has its own tartan.
And I suspect that Mr. Dwyer is going to be asking you to change to those colors.
But we'll see when he speaks.
Commissioner's question.
I think just to repeat what's already been said, that they're not visible from either the olive side and the other ones in the alley.
I think you'll be able to see them, but they're not on the two main exposures of the building.
You probably had me at global warming, but I'm going to agree with Mr. Dwyer on the Kelly Green here.
Commissioner's questions for the appellant.
Okay, thank you very much, sir, Mr dryer.
Yes, Mr Chairman.
I am James Dwyer I reside in 63108 and I affirm that I will tell the truth.
Thank you.
The CWE Planning and Development Committee has reviewed the proposal to install two canvas awnings at the reference address and recognizes that the proposed installation is non-compliant with the relevant provisions of the CWE Historic District Standards requiring that, quote, all awnings shall fit within the openings to which they are affixed, and that, therefore, the Cultural Resources Office must deny the application.
Following due consideration, the committee has determined that given the intended purpose of the awnings, that is to address the prospect of stormwater overwhelming exterior area drains and flooding the basement, as well as the proposed locations of the awnings on secondary elevations, alley and parking lot, an exception to the rule is warranted in this instance.
However, the committee recommends that the proposed color of the awnings, green, be reconsidered and that a neutral shade of beige or gray be specified to blend into the color of the building and minimize the visual impact of the canvas.
Subject to that condition, the committee recommends favorable action on the appeal.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Anybody else, Bob?
No, sir.
Okay, Commissioners, that concludes testimony on this appeal.
Do I hear a motion?
Commissioner Robinson.
I move that we overturn the Director's denial
and to prove the awning with the stipulation that the color be a beige or light gray to blend with the existing facade.
Great.
Does your motion note that this is a variance?
Yes.
Okay.
Due to structural conditions and placement?
Yes.
Okay.
Is there a second?
I'll second.
Motion made and seconded.
Is there any discussion?
Okay.
Commissioners, I'm going to call a roll.
Commissioner Robinson, do you vote yes or no on your own motion?
Yes.
Commissioner Colleen, nope.
Commissioner Allen, do you vote yes or no on your motion?
Yes.
Commissioner Hamacher, do you vote yes or no on your motion?
Alderman Coder, do you vote yes or no on your motion?
Yes.
Chair abstains on this motion.
That is Commissioner's four yeses.
One abstention and one recusal, the appeal is upheld.
Thank you all.
Thank you for your consideration.
Okay, moving through this.
Commissioners, agenda item C is 4555 Pershing Place.
All right, I am Andrea Gagan with the Cultural Resources Office, and I swear to tell the truth.
This is 4555 Pershing Place.
I need to enter into the record the agenda item, the presentation, the PowerPoint.
The Central West End Ordinance 56768 is amended by 69423.
The Naval Union Ordinance 64689 as amended by 64925.
Three letters for neighbors, one from the Board of PPIA, one from the Central West End Planning and Development Committee, and one from Alderman Gross.
And those are all in support of the appeal.
And will your testimony be the truth?
Yes.
This is the location at the corner of Walton and Pershing Place.
And this is the existing rear elevation and the rear porch in question.
The applicant has applied for interior and exterior alterations on a single family home, including the removal of a rear porch and new rear addition.
Given that the existing porch is in the same footprint shown on the 1909 Sanborn map,
and that no documentation has been provided to dispute the originality of the porch, staff presumes the porch to be original to the house.
Now, I believe the applicant has some photos now that they're going to show, but we hadn't received them before today.
The Cultural Resources Office denied the permit application as the St.
Louis standards do not allow for the removal of a historic porch that is visible from the street.
The owner has appealed, and the matter is now being brought before the Preservation Board.
As I said, this is the existing rear porch and a view from Walton.
Proposed addition would require the removal of the historic rear porch and the historic district standards require that original or historic porches be preserved through in-kind maintenance and repair.
Here is just the side elevations showing the proposed addition in a rear elevation which
shows a section drawing of the patio area that they're adding, and then an elevation of the rear of the addition.
The majority of the work on the permit application complies with the Central West End Historic District standards.
The removal of the visible porch at the rear of the building does not comply.
Although the addition itself would be compliant,
with the standards may not be completed without the removal of the rear porch.
So the Cultural Resources Office recommends the Preservation Board uphold the director's denial as a proposal.
Removal of the rear porch and construction of a rear addition does not comply with the Southwestern Historic District Standards.
Just to clarify, you're asking us to consider removal of the porch, not the quality of the addition.
Correct.
And looking at your screen there, how many people have signed up to speak besides the appellant?
Let's see.
OK, just one.
Actually, there's two other than the, because that's not the, oh, I guess, yeah, that's just one other than the owner, I believe.
Although, I don't know.
the alderman, so I don't speak.
Okay, what's your final answer?
Just one person?
One other than the applicant, yeah.
Great, thank you.
Let's hear from the appellant.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
Mr. Chairman, I apologize, but I did enter into a single entry in the chat that I hoped to speak on both the previous matter and this one.
I, I assumed that Miss Gagan was addressing you in your role as the informal alderman.
And I was going to call on you anyway.
Yeah, it went to the wrong chat.
I think that was problem.
Good enough.
We'll remember you when the time comes.
Let's hear from the appellant.
Hi, everybody.
Zach Foster here.
This is my wife, Janie Foster.
Zip code 63108.
And we swear to tell the truth.
Perfect.
That's good till midnight.
Really enjoying the comedy show, Mr. Callow.
So thank you for that.
Completely unintended.
Proceed, please.
What do you want us to do?
Yeah, great.
Really appreciate the time, everyone.
We moved into 4555 Pershing Place in 2014.
We now have two young girls.
We've been working diligently on our own and with a team to
the standards of the house to get it in a place for the next 100 years.
This is our forever home.
This is where we want to be.
We've scoured every source possible, including Missouri Historical Society, to try to find additional documentation that proves one way or the other the condition and state of our current porch, the north-facing porch.
We have the 1909 drawings as noted before.
In lieu of additional documentation, we've turned to physical evidence within the house.
I'll hand it over to my wife to fill in some of the details there.
On the next slide, if it's possible to go there.
Beneath the porch you can see again this is just sort of some sleuthing and evidence gathering that we've done on our own because the only thing that we've been able to uncover is that 1909 kind of pencil outline drawing of the home.
There is clearly a bricked in
opening that was once there, whether it was a window or a coal chute of some sort, we do not know.
But based on the outside and the way the port sits down there, it would have obscured the original intention of that opening.
You can see it from the inside, too, for your viewing pleasure.
There's one other bit of evidence that unfortunately is not in this
presentation, if you don't mind us adding it in there, there are some pockmarks on the side of the home that show that perhaps this porch had a different sizing shape that maybe is more in line with that 1909
drawing that is sort of what we're going off of here.
There's also a door up on the second floor that suggests that there was some sort of usage from that second floor.
The current porch as it stands would not support weight on the roof.
So,
We've done everything that we can to try to preserve and understand the history of this part of the house.
We've also turned to neighbors for precedent with this sort of things, rear porches that set behind fences, and both neighbors directly of Caddy Corner Trust on the corner of Lenox and Walton recently
removed a dilapidated porch.
in favor of an updated one that is quite sizable, includes a kitchen expansion within it, and it's enclosed with windows, similar to what we're presenting.
And then also our neighbor directly east of us, you can see in one of the earlier photos, there's ghost lines of the porch that was removed just in 2020 in favor of a modern deck that goes across the whole side of the house.
So that is what we have.
Our intention, as my husband said, our intention is to maintain the integrity of our home.
We love our home.
We love our neighborhood.
We are deeply invested in the Central West End, and we have great respect for the homes that were built there in the early 1900s.
and we are preserving the front of the home to what we hope is a T, and we are hoping to push this home into a place where it can stand for families the next 100 years.
Did you happen to notice if the Sandbergs have a pool?
That they have a pool?
Do they?
Yeah.
John and Celeste.
Yes.
And they have not invited me over.
How dare they?
I can't speak to that.
I have been to that pool.
It's very nice.
I will be making some notes on this subject.
And also extraneous to this conversation.
Commissioner's questions for the appellant.
I have one question.
I'm looking at the photograph here.
Thank you, these help.
And that wood evident on the right hand photograph doesn't look very old to me.
Do you think any of the materials on this porch are original at this point?
So we replaced the stairs on the porch because they were rotting.
And in the process of replacing the stairs, the contractor who did the work, he found that there were quite a few new pieces that had been put on the porch, around the porch, newer uprights to support the porch.
I'm sorry that we do not have a picture of these pockmarks.
We are trying to find ghost lines and such like that.
These are substantial pockmarks that run parallel to the current porch just east of the porch as seen from the rear of the house.
That suggests it had a different footprint originally than what is there now.
Thank you.
I mean, I'll say I did examine the 1909 map, and if you map that onto your house, the original porch would have extended to the midline, and the current porch does not, so those drawings are all to scale, so I don't know.
Just a little of my own investigation.
Thanks.
Yeah, thank you.
If there's any further questions?
Okay.
Alderman Grass, are you here?
I am you want to speak first or last.
I don't care, I you know I sent a letter in that I think has most my comments, I think sums it up, you know I was really just I think that the exception should be made here, you know the the porches in the back and doesn't contribute much I think to the.
To the House, I think this addition is pretty important to the residents on to keep them here, I really just popped in, though, to say that.
you know, I wrote that letter, I didn't even really realize that there was kind of this question of whether or not the porch was even original.
And, you know, kind of hearing some of it, you know, I feel like, you know, there's a big enough question of fact about whether or not this porch is even original to begin with.
But even if it is, I'd certainly still be in favor of the exception.
Great.
Thank you, sir.
Mr. Dreier, are you still here?
Yes, I am.
Okay, you're still under oath.
Good, then I will proceed.
Mr. Chairman and members of the board, the issue on appeal today, that is whether to permit the demolition of an existing rear porch to allow construction of a new two-story addition is a matter on which there are conflicting views among members of the CWE planning and development committee.
I will note here that had we known what we just learned about
the additional information that was not available until today, perhaps the dynamics of that conversation among committee members might have changed.
But nevertheless, based on what we knew at the time, we agreed that the proposed demolition would violate the applicable provisions of the Central West End Historic District Standards, and that it is not the practice of the committee to endorse proposals that conflict with the standards.
We also recognize that there are rare occasions on which exceptions may warrant consideration.
When such exceptions have occurred, they've been justified based on a subjective evaluation of the relative merits of that which is proposed versus the perceived consequences of the demolition.
Such was the case when in March of 2022,
The committee offered a favorable recommendation regarding the proposed demolition of the residential structure at 4952-54 McPherson Avenue to accommodate new construction related to the adaptive reuse of the adjacent Reliance Automotive property.
In this instance,
It is agreed that the design of the proposed addition would warrant a favorable recommendation from the committee, were it not for the demolition, and that the existing porch, while highly visible, is located on the rear elevation and is arguably not a defining feature of the house.
Following considerable deliberation, the committee has concluded that it will not oppose the proposed demolition.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Commissioners, that concludes the testimony we have on this matter.
Commissioner Killeen, have you got a motion?
Yes, Mr. Chairman.
I move that the Preservation Board override the director's denial of this and let the porch demolition occur.
And that demolition would be pending a building permit for the new structure before it is allowed.
Is there a second?
Second.
Discussion?
Commissioners, it is my belief that that is not an original porch, and that we don't need a variance for this.
We're not proposing to demolish a original porch, but rather a replacement porch.
Totally agree, Mr. Chairman.
Any further discussion?
OK, commissioners, I'm going to call a roll.
On this motion, Commissioner Robinson, do you vote yes or no?
Yes.
On your motion, Commissioner Killeen, do you vote yes or no?
On this motion, Commissioner Allen, do you vote yes or no?
Yes.
On this motion, Commissioner Hamacher, do you vote yes or no?
On this motion, Alderman Coder, do you vote yes or no?
Yes.
The chair abstains on this, counts five yeses and one abstention.
The appeal is upheld.
Thank you all.
Thank you, commissioners.
If you see John and Celeste, you might mention that Calla wants to know where the heck his invitation is.
Got it.
If you have a dog, that's favorable.
They let our dog in before they let us in.
Yep, that sounds like them.
Yeah.
Thank you all very much.
Sure.
Okay, commissioners, let's move on to agenda item D, which is 5806 Westminster Place.
Okay, I'm actually going to merge 5806 and 5808 Westminster.
One is an appeal and the other is a new application.
but they are on neighboring parcels and basically the same building.
The same applicant and owner.
For a second there, Barb, can we do this?
My only concern would be for clarity on appeal.
I'm thinking that this is one structure that's proposed for two address flats, is that correct?
No, it's two separate buildings, but there's separate lots.
They're just next to each other.
And the review one of one kind of depends on the other because of the visibility of the sides.
Um, so I mean, you do the first one and sort of interject when it's appropriate.
And then when you get to the second one, um, you can state that some of it is substantially the same as what we've heard.
Does that sound reasonable?
Yeah, I guess.
I was just going to do ask for two separate things at the end, but that's fine.
So the proposal is to construct a detached, oh actually let me go ahead and enter the agenda item, the PowerPoint, the presentation, and the enabling ordinance 648689 is
sorry, in the state of Oliver, Catlin Tract, Parkview, Historic District Standards, Ordinance 57688, as amended by 70821.
And my testimony will be the truth.
All right, so this is a lot that is two partials.
The one closest to construction is 5806.
This just kind of shows the location, which is close to Laurel and Westminster.
This is the site plan on the left for 5806 Westminster.
The lot is slightly narrower than the one next to it.
This is a proposed treescape, which shows the two buildings.
The one on the left is the 5806, which is the one we're dealing with right now.
And this is the reference building in the Skinkinapoliver Historic District.
You don't have to have a model example, but they did base it on one of the neighboring buildings.
so that it will be compatible with the neighborhood.
And then this is just the front elevation.
And they are changing the second-story door to, right now it's like a half-glass door.
They're changing it to a three-quarter full light, as we had asked.
And these are the side elevations.
For this, one of the, actually this building is totally within the historic district standards as far as the returns on the sides.
They, speaking of Oliver, requires the width of the, between the buildings plus two feet.
None of the buildings are more than 10 feet apart and the extensions are 13 feet.
feet 8 inches.
And this is just the rear elevation.
And this is context to the east, which our new construction that were built quite a few years ago at this point, and then context west on the street, and then the context across Westminster.
buildings substantially comply with the Skinker, Bolliger, Catlin, Track, Parkview Local Historic District Standards.
And for 5806 Westminster, the Cultural Resources Office recommends the Preservation Board overturn the Director's Administrative Denial with a stipulation that final plans and exterior materials be reviewed and approved by the Cultural Resources Office.
Quick question, why was it administratively denied?
Just due to time constraints, because they originally, they had only applied for one building, and that would require them to do a full brick or an upgrade on the side elevation as far as the material.
So we were waiting on them to apply for the second building so that we could review it all at the same time.
So do they have building permits for both applications?
Yes, now they've applied.
Yes, they have an application for both now.
OK.
Tell me, is there anybody here to speak for or against this besides the appellant?
I don't believe so.
I don't think anybody signed up, although I thought that the
Applicant is here, though.
It's Ramon Sarmento.
OK.
Commissioners, the testimony that we just heard is that this project complies and substantially complies with all of the requirements.
Do we need to hear from the appellant?
I don't think so.
OK.
Commissioner Allen, have you got a motion for agenda item D?
Yes, agenda item D. So I move that the Preservation Board overturn the Director's Administrative Denial of the current design with stipulation that final plans and exterior materials be reviewed and approved by the Cultural Resources Office.
Is there a second?
Second.
Any discussion?
Hearing none, I'll call a roll.
Commissioner Robinson, do you vote yes or no?
Yes.
Commissioner Colleen, do you vote yes or no?
Commissioner Allen, do you vote yes or no?
Yes.
Commissioner Hamacher, do you vote yes or no?
Alderman Coder, do you vote yes or no?
Yes.
Chair abstains on this matter.
I count one, two, three, four, five yeses.
The appeal is upheld.
Commissioner Allen, while I have you, have you got a motion on agenda item E?
Can I just move that we adopt the previous rule?
Or do I have to make a motion?
No, you can.
All right, I move that we adopt the previous rule.
Do we need a motion first, Chairman?
Yeah, would you make a motion to?
PB, David Ensign  Herndon, COB?s iPhone 2?s iPhone 3?s iPhone 4?s iPhone 5?s iPhone 6?s iPhone 7?s iPhone 8?s iPhone 9?s iPhone 10?s iPhone 11?s iPhone 12?s iPhone 13?s iPhone 14?s iPhone 15?s iPhone 16?s iPhone 17?s iPhone 18?s iPhone 19?s iPhone 20?s iPhone 21?s iPhone 22?s iPhone 23?s iPhone 24?s iPhone 25?s iPhone 26?s iPhone 27?s iPhone 28?s iPhone 29?s iPhone 30?s iPhone 31?s iPhone 32?s iPhone 33?s iPhone 33?s iPhone 34?s iPhone 35?s iPhone 36?s iPhone 37?s
Hey, I'm back.
We're back to director best Well, I don't.
Let's not do that to myself.
Like, Mike is a great job.
Let's jinx that shall we.
Okay.
I'm gonna go ahead and enter in all this stuff just for the sake of consistency, you know, it's a new application.
64689, as amended by 69423, a Benton Park ordinance, 67175, presentation, PowerPoint, step report, and I still do live at 63139 in beautiful Clifton Heights.
Okay, to make the record clear, are we hearing F and G together?
Yeah, I was gonna say that next.
Just for clarity's sake, yeah, they're both new applications, they're not separate,
They're identical designs, they're side-by-side, two different parcels, but I figured, yeah, just do it at the same time, that's okay.
Same applicant.
This is a preliminary review, is that okay with you?
No, it's a new application.
Sorry, it is a new application, not an administrative appeal.
So it's one project, yes.
Yeah, one project by one developer, but two different buildings on two different parcels, two applications.
The complexity of trying to separate that out as you prepare it, but the board did a good job of addressing both agenda items separately in the last instance, so it's kind of similar.
Except in the other case, one was an appeal and one was a new application.
Correct.
I hate it when somebody agrees with me and I still don't win.
Yeah.
Okay, we'll just do two motions, but Bob, do one presentation.
Sounds good.
Okay, so this is the site in question.
3315 and 3317 Lemp in the Benton Park Local Historic District.
Yeah, the property used to contain a large, I believe it was a two-story, three-story, three-family building.
It was a large building that was demolished, I believe, in like 2015, 16.
Here's the location.
just south of the park.
Here's some street-level context for you.
Obviously, the empty lot on the left picture on the slide is the location.
Across the street are really some great new infill that we have had over the past few years in Benton Park.
So this block has a lot of new construction on it, so it's a lot of diverse
context architecturally, you have a one-story commercial to one side and you have three stories, so it's the block has various heights, setbacks, ages of buildings, styles of buildings, so it's a really kind of a really cool diverse block.
This is looking south along that and it kind of continues that theme of new construction and various heights of buildings and setbacks.
Here is a streetscape showing the two new buildings in context with the adjacent buildings.
You can see that, for the most part, the fenestration will align with the properties to the north.
Obviously, we have some lower-scale stuff to the south.
This is the proposed front elevation, and the model example is seen on the right on Illinois.
These are the elevations.
All the elevations are uniform on all four sides.
They'll be the same on each unit.
And then you have the rear elevation, same as both.
So some context.
I'm going to back up a little bit.
I appear to have neglected to add a site plan.
That is on me, so I sincerely apologize for that.
But I will say that the buildings do align.
with the property to the south.
But again, the block is varied.
So the Preservation Board actually has seen this design from this developer before.
Back in 2019, the Preservation Board approved this very design for a property over on Illinois.
So at that time, staff recommended approval, as we're going to today.
I want you to know that essentially everything on the front facade is what you saw in 2019.
There really is no deviation.
The brick returns to an appropriate distance on the sides.
There's like six-ish feet, barely, on the south side.
And then on the north side, I think about eight feet.
Returns are going to go back about 12 feet on the sides on H1.
So, again, you've seen it before, and we, at that time, we did recommend approval.
So just going through the code really quickly, complies with setback, alignment.
We feel the mass is appropriate.
The scale of the buildings are also appropriate.
Proportion wise, we feel that it meets the model example in terms of fenestration as brick to opening ratio complies.
The front elevation will be a red brick.
Foundation will be a painted concrete gray.
So everything else does comply for the most part.
There are some minor deviations just for the
level of detail for some of the proportions, but overall, it does comply and staff is recommending approval of the designs as submitted to be consistent with what we approved previously.
You were sent a letter this afternoon from Benton Park.
Mr. Mulligan is here to speak on the item again.
So if you have any questions, again, staff recommends that the board
approve the new applications subject to the conditions that final details, drawings, and other materials, exterior materials, and colors for the house be reviewed and approved by CRO.
Question about windows, Bob.
Yes, sir.
Are we going to allow them to tint the windows or are they going to be clear?
They should be clear.
Those pictures you guys just showed of the new projects across the street, they're all tinted, which is against the guidelines.
I just looked it up.
Section 203L31 says no tinted glass, and there it is.
And the new one going up at the corner of Salina Street and Crittenden also, I mean, they just put the windows in, they're all tinted.
So I don't know how we can stop these folks from putting in tinted windows.
I can't imagine you guys are allowing that, but it's happening all over Benton Park.
Yeah, well, we will look into that.
Thank you.
Further questions for Bob?
OK, let's hear from the applicant.
Wait, Bob, who besides Tim is here to speak?
So we have just the applicant, and Tim Mulligan is here from Benton Park.
Perfect.
Let's have the applicant up.
We probably have some questions.
Sure.
Orlando Askins.
Um, forgive me.
I forgot what I was supposed to say.
Um, other than I will tell the truth.
Okay.
Um, actually, I'm not even going to square you in on a new application, but we probably have some questions for you commissioners.
No questions.
Okay.
Mr. Askins, have you read the conditions proposed by the cultural resources office?
I've read the recommendations.
Do you agree?
I do.
Are you going to tint those windows?
I don't know where that's coming from.
I've never tinted a window before.
OK, then.
You made at least one commissioner happy.
Good.
Happy to do so.
How many other ones do I have to make happy?
Let's see.
Five, six?
We'll see how it goes.
Stand by, Mr. Atkins.
Mr. Mulligan, do you want to say something?
Uh, yes, I, we would request that this be deferred until we have time to meet with the applicant.
Uh, this, uh, we were made aware of this after the February 8th.
Committee meeting that we had and that this was, I'm not sure why it was.
Uh, uh, put on the agenda so quickly, uh, but we are not, um,
Delighted with the way a previous project of Mr. Askins turned out on Illinois Avenue.
Furthermore, the window patterns in the model to what has been built and what is proposed really don't line up.
I mean, those are all divided windows.
And I think one of the other things that we noticed was missing would be
window that's at the basement level on the front of the house.
The house that's on the 3317 shows the vinyl siding returning whatever the appropriate distance is, 8 feet or 10 feet.
But that is a one-story building to the south of that.
Over the top of that building, you will see
you know, all of the vinyl siding.
So as you can see with the photographs from across the street, you know, where we had that condition, we work with the developer to return the brick, you know, to the back edge of that part of the building.
You know, so I think there's some details that just need to be, you know, firmed up here and made to better align
you know, with the model example.
May I introduce or say something really quick about the windows?
Actually, let me ask you a question.
Sure.
Do you want to talk to these people before we decide?
I'm not really certain what there is to discuss other than we're building the exact same thing that we built in the past.
As far as split windows, we didn't do split windows.
They're solid one piece windows.
There's no split windows on this property.
And then he speaks of a front window in the basement.
Well, the plans never called for that.
So we didn't put one in.
Um, and we used them.
I mean, they were approved as it sits currently.
So, um, we didn't leave a window out by choice.
It just wasn't in the plans.
And then also, as he said something about a split window, um, the model match on 3313 has split windows, but ours were solid one piece windows and that's what was approved.
So we, we followed it to, as to the plans.
So I don't mind working with them, but I just don't know what else could be added to what has already been approved.
That's what I'm saying.
OK, thank you, Mr. Haskins.
Chairman, may I ask clarity?
This is a new application for a permit.
Has the application been filed?
Yes.
Chairman, could you ask the cultural resource office in their file?
It appears to me that they have 50 days from the date of an application to grant or deny the permit, but I don't know where we are in that period.
So, we mean, the applied.
the application back on the 6th of February.
So we're still within that first window for application.
It's not even been denied yet.
So we haven't even started that clock.
So there's plenty of time to bring the item back if need be.
We can even deny it and then come back as an admin.
But we have plenty of time to work with the applicant.
Commissioners, what's your pleasure?
Commissioner Allen, what do you think?
I move to defer, Mr. Chairman.
Is the motion on the floor?
Is there a second?
I second.
The motion on the floor has been made and seconded.
Is there any discussion?
Hearing none, all those in favor of deferring agenda items F and G, signify by saying aye.
Aye.
Opposed?
Commissioner Hamacher, you are making me laugh.
Sorry.
It is fine.
I believe that the motion carries.
Commissioners, that concludes the business that we have before us.
Does anybody have anything to add for the good of the order?
Hearing nothing, Commissioner Hamacher, good luck.
Thank you.
Speedy delivery on the boy.
Or a girl.
OK.
Do I hear a motion to adjourn?
So moved.
Any objection?
Hearing none, we stand adjourned.
Thank you, commissioners.
Take care, guys.
Thanks, everyone.